and so the san antonio spurs
have their consecutive playoff
streak of 22 straight seasons
snapped utah beat them 118
to 112. listen in
the spurs play playoffs straight just
just having it and your thoughts on it
i don't have any thoughts it doesn't it
doesn't
i don't it doesn't enter my mind just to
evaluate the whole performance there in
orlando uh you guys obviously
streak it all before it ended
was this important when it ended
okay yeah yeah i'm just screwing with
you
but looking at the pass doesn't do much
good so any success we've had has been
because we've had some
great players i'm thrilled at the way
they played here
they had no shot to get into this thing
and
basically wheeled themselves into it to
have this opportunity
this is the best we've played all year
sounds like your coach is excited about
the possibility of coaching these guys
in the future you expect to see us again
in a few months
why wouldn't i people are afraid that
you might walk away
are you trying to flatter me here's the
deal
i talk to people all the time they call
me they tell you [ __ ] the streak didn't
end
it didn't it didn't end i don't know
where you guys are getting this
it's total fake news